have you ever been asked to be one of
these superheroes or anything like that
not a superhero no I've never actually
auditioned for him because I kind of for
one thing you have to sign up to do
eight movies and then and I just cut out
I was like eight is just a lot so but I
mean the dough I guess and I know that's
a tough one because look at Downey jr. I
mean he's tearing it up yeah I mean when
you when you when you're like I mean
definitely a dependent all depends on
the character I mean it's kind of it's
just always difficult tonight but that's
definitely what kind of made me a little
hesitant before cuz it's kind of you
know when you're just an individual you
have to really commit to like working
within the machine with a huge machine
when you mate why light did you realize
that it was gonna change your life like
it was gonna put you in the realm of
like a list movie star can get lots of
different role like did you sense it no
not on the first one not all right and
then kind of so it shocked you when it
came out and the thing made like
hundreds of millions of dollars yeah I
mean I thought cuz like before the
director the first one was a kind of
indie director she done some sort of
cool stuff and then I just kind of
thought it was yeah I thought it was
gonna be I thought isn't me a little
kind of cool movie it was a big-budget
or anything it was 37 million and it
grossed like hundreds of millions of
dollars thirty seven million 37 million
was the first one didn't get very much
of that no you didn't I think playing a
vampire
you got a really come in there with some
sort of game and the word on Twilight
was like you took it so seriously when
you got that part that you almost got
kicked off that set I mean I just
thought you know considering now now
it's known to be this a very emo thing I
mean there was a period I was just you
know I thought it's very very series
just kind of thought at the time it's
like 21 that you haven't if you're going
into a relationship with someone the way
to make it really intense is if like you
can barely talk to each other you can
barely touch each other incredibly
serious all the time I mean it's kind of
like what teenage relationships are like
and that's what sort of makes it feel
like that but everyone kind of wanted it
today no they should be like happy and
having fun that's what people want and
that's kind of you know that's that's
the sort of teen romance thing you
wanted it brooding
yeah I was right now that the whole
series is known as the cab routing thing
but yeah they're kind of I remember that
produce has given me a copy of the book
and it's like every single instance was
my character smiled and stuff she they
highlighted everything so you put your
foot down you said hey listen man I
don't see the character that way I'm not
gonna I got the same but I got a
different color highlighter and
highlight it all it's how many frowns
and did your agents put pressure on you
and stuff to say hey you better just get
with the program or they're gonna fire
you oh yeah they came they flew up and
said like you could cuz I thought I was
pretty safe right there and they flew up
and they're like yeah you could you have
to do the opposite of what you're doing
now you're gonna get fired today so how
did you hold your ground I mean how did
you know what to do I didn't I literally
came back off that game like oh you
can't even do what you want